wir haben wir machen weiter mit einem
unglaublichen fall der einfach nur
sprachlos und unfassbar wütend macht in
dortmund soll ein 23 jahre alter mann am
freitag eine 13 jährige vergewaltigt
haben jetzt kommt raus er hatte gerade
mal vor einem monat bereits eine 11
jährige vergewaltigt der skandal auf
antrag der staatsanwaltschaft wurde er
nach der ersten tat wieder freigelassen
jörg decker ist mir jetzt live aus
dortmund zugeschaltet hallo dirk was
wissen wir dann über den täter der ja
nach der ersten tat wieder freigelassen
wurde
der täter ist ein afghane der wohl
vorläufig bleiberecht hier in
deutschland auch einen festen wohnsitz
verfügt und das war auch letztendlich
die begründung der staatsanwaltschaft
ihn wieder freizulassen
es kann natürlich keiner verstehen dass
ein so schwerwiegendes delikt wie die
vergewaltigung einer elfjährigen zur
tatzeit mittlerweile ist dass menschen
12 trotzdem der täter oder der
mutmassliche täter dann wieder auf
freiem fuß gelangen konnte denn genau
zwei wochen später nachdem er im grund
genommen aus der u haft wieder entlassen
worden war hat er unweit von dieser
stelle wo ich jetzt stehe auf einem
spielplatz ein mädchen angesprochen hat
sie wohl in den hausflur hinter mir
gelockt wir können die tür auch mal
aufmachen das schreckliche verbrechen
passierte dann im hausflur im inneren
und im erdgeschoss die aus bewohner
soweit wir sie denn sprechen können
selbst sehr viele menschen mit
migrationshintergrund haben wohl
offenbar von der tat nichts mitbekommen
einige konnten nur davon berichten dass
sie am freitag nach polizei im
ausführlichen hetzen aber wo genau die
tat stattgefunden hatte das konnten sie
uns auch nicht sagen